Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In 2019, researchers at OpenAI came up with
an amazing learning algorithm that they deployed
on a robot hand that was able to dexterously
manipulate a Rubik’s cube…even when it
was severely hamstrung. A good game plan to
perform such a thing, is to first, solve the
problem in a computer simulation where we
can learn and iterate quickly, and then, transfer
everything the agent learned there to the
real world, and hope that it obtained general
knowledge that indeed can be applied to real
tasks. Papers like these are some of my favorites.
If you are one of our core Fellow Scholars,
you may also remember that we talked about
walking robots about 200 episodes ago. In
this amazing paper, we witnessed a robot not
only learning to walk, but, it could also
adjust its behavior and keep walking, even
if one or multiple legs lose power, or get
damaged. In this previous work, the key idea
was to allow the robot to learn tasks such
as walking not only in one, optimal way, but
to explore and build a map of many alternative
motions relying on different body parts.
Both of these papers teach us that working
in the real world often shows us new, unexpected
challenges to overcome. And, this new paper
offers a technique to adapt a robot arm to
these challenges after it has been deployed
into the real world. It is supposed to be
able to pick up objects, which sounds somewhat
simple these days…until we realize that
new, previously unseen objects may appear
in the bin with different shapes, or material
models. For example, reflective and refractive
objects are particularly perilous because
they often show us more about their surroundings
than about themselves, lighting conditions
may also change after deployment, the gripper’s
length or shape may change, and many, many
other issues are likely to arise.
Let’s have a look at the lighting conditions
part. Why would that be such an issue? The
objects are the same, the scene looks nearly
the same, so, why is this a challenge? Well,
if the lighting changes, the reflections change
significantly, and since the robot arm sees
its reflection and thinks that it is a different
object, it just keeps trying to grasp it.
After some fine-tuning, this method was able
to increase the otherwise not too pleasant
32% success rate to 63%. Much, much better.
Also, extending the gripper used to be somewhat
of a problem, but as you see here, with this
technique, it is barely an issue anymore.
Also, if we have a somewhat intelligent system,
and we move position of the gripper around,
nothing really changes, so we would expect
it to perform well. Does it? Well, let’s
have a look! Unfortunately, it just seems
to be rotating around without too many meaningful
actions. And now, hold on to your papers,
because after using this continual learning
scheme, yes! It improved substantially and
makes very few mistakes, and can even pick
up these tiny objects that are very challenging
to grasp with this clumsy hand.
This fine-tuning step typically takes an additional
hour, or at most a few hours of extra training,
and can used to help these AIs learn continuously
after they are deployed in the real world,
thereby updating and improving themselves.
It is hard to define what exactly intelligence
is, but an important component of it is being
able to reuse knowledge and adapt to new,
unseen situations. This is exactly what this
paper helps with. Absolute witchcraft. What
a time to be alive!
This episode has been supported by Linode.
Linode is the world’s largest independent
cloud computing provider. Unlike entry-level
hosting services, Linode gives you full backend
access to your server, which is your step
up to powerful, fast, fully configurable cloud
computing. Linode also has One-Click Apps
that streamline your ability to deploy websites,
personal VPNs, game servers, and more. If
you need something as small as a personal
online portfolio, Linode has your back, and
if you need to manage tons of client’s websites
and reliably serve them to millions of visitors,
Linode can do that too. What’s more, they
offer affordable GPU instances featuring the
Quadro RTX 6000 which is tailor-made for AI,
scientific computing and computer graphics
projects. If only I had access to a tool like
this while I was working on my last few papers!
To receive $20 in credit on your new Linode
account, visitlinode.com/papersor click
the link in the description and give it a
try today! Our thanks to Linode for supporting
the series and helping us make better videos
for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!